hey guys merry here at PAX Prime 2015
and we are working with the mix here at
pax to bring you guys the latest and
greatest indie games I am here with
David from brain and brain hey how's it
going good I am and today you're gonna
show me a game that I looked at a
screenshot and said yeah I kind of want
to play it's called burly men at sea
barely menacing yeah so really meant to
see is a folktale style adventure about
three bearded fishermen you'd go on an
adventure at sea let's get started I'll
give you a glimpse so they start by
finding this map in a bottle which is a
mysterious mysterious map and the entire
game is controlled by moving this mask
wiki just saw media so you don't
actually control the characters directly
you control the the camera on the
environment around them so they find
this map and what you're going to see on
screen here but strangely it's a map
with nothing on it just their own Island
that they're from so their first mission
is to go figure out what to do with it
so I'm just kind of moving through the
dialogue a little bit quickly here but
they're going to go to the village and
see what anyone can tell them so the
entire game is about these three
freshmen and we tell it through
narrative story book sequences along
with a more traditional gameplay or you
can die explore environments and
discover how to move forward we're
trying to cast you as the story time not
the characters so you control the
characters indirectly and you make
decisions while playing the game that
determine the story that the characters
go through okay so you can have
different types of story based on your
elements or you're always going to go
through the same story you can have a
completely different experience about
three or four times without like any
crossover at all the beginning in the
end are going to be similar but the
holes at the center of the game is very
different that's awesome so what are
these burly men doing they Bailey fit in
this tiny house yeah their beards
certainly barely fit through the door
they're so this is the fishing villages
where they're from and they're wanting
to find out more about this math that
they found so so your first mission is
to go around and talk to the people in
the village see what they know so that
burly men are called the brothers beard
we have hasty beard brave beard and
steady
okay right now hasty grades interrupting
steady Barry because he just can't wait
for anything and it turns out that the
villagers are very ordinary and they
like it that way and very limit are too
but this map is a little bit different
and so we're going to go talk to someone
at the other end of the village who they
kind of ignore this old man in a coffee
shop and he can probably give us some
more information the entire game is
vector graphics so what you're seeing
here is real-time vector graphics
everything's an SVG file so it's totally
resolution independent which is kind of
fun we could make a huge and it looks
great and we're husband and wife team my
wife did all the artwork and I'm the
programmer and sound designer so many a
husband-and-wife teams I'm hearing about
it's pretty cool you guys get to work
together all the time it's fun it's
really fun yeah it does have a vector
art style to like you'd almost look at
this and say it almost looks like an
infographic or something like sure
interactive which makes it really nice
yeah my wife said she was a graphic
designer before getting into games so
that certainly comes out her work so now
we're talking to old beard and he has
alienation the whole game is inspired by
Scandinavian fishing villages but also
Scandinavian folklore okay so once we
leave the village which I don't know a
lot of time to do in this demo but once
you leave the village you start
encountering mythical creatures really
there are no humans after this
everything's like Krakens or ninja
surges crazy creatures from minutes of
mythology and know if it's based on the
folklore you're saying those maybe like
hints of truths in it that you're you're
borrowing from books that you've read it
yeah definitely uh Brooke did a lot of
research Anders there's a little bits of
truth in I think every mythology and
that's a lot of the fun all right so
we're what are we learning about right
now we're speed reading through them
yeah yeah I'm colleges for that so we're
showing old beard the map and old beard
deliberates and says that what we have
is a map that brings about adventurous
deeds and heroic feats so the game is
about about the journey that you go on
it's a it's an adventure about adventure
is one thing we like to say about it so
the burly men are discovering that maybe
not having a destination is okay maybe
maybe that's the fun and what makes an
adventure is not knowing where you're
going to go it's a worthwhile adventure
that begin
the unknown so as you go through the
game your map will be filled out with
the the choices that you make and the
things that you encounter along the way
all the way you guys are animating as
well it's kind of a very unique way that
you're going about things here of fire
is half circles all you guys have
obviously kind of doing things in your
own perspective and your own unique art
style and I think I think it's got its
own very unique flair to it you don't
see a lot of games with this look Thank
You yeah we're trying to be as minimal
as we can be without making it difficult
to understand what's going on I wish we
could see the nymphs this is kind of
like just the very beginning just a
taste yeah I'm very excited to see where
it goes from here do you guys have a
release date or a window that you're
looking at so we're looking at a late
2015 released on steam and iOS okay so
steam and iOS four burly men at sea
start here first thank you so much to
thank you sweet and so that was that was
burly men at see if you guys like that
be sure to stay tuned to gamespot com
for the latest games